GAMES IN LAVAL.
GAME ONE OF IS  --
VERSUS
>> Bryan: AND A GOOD RETURN FOR
KIRK MULLER AS WELL TO THE BELL
CENTRE, NOW AN ASSISTANT COA SC!
THE TIP IN FRONT AS BACKLUND GOT
HISIS TO
A GOOD STARUKI SPUN AROUND AND
IT TO TYLER TOFFOLI.
TOFFOLI O OLAP SHOT, REBOUNT 5-
LINEUP THAT
HE'S USE TODAY,
YEAH, I PLAYED AT THE FORUM,
GUYS, I COACHED AT THE B BIS FIN
GAMES.
KULAK UP FLKING IN, BACK
FOR HO TOFFOLI IN TIGHT GETS A
NOW. WHACK AT THE
>> Bryan: JOHNNY GAUDREAU
CENTRES, LEHKONEN ABLE TO STEER
PHYSICAL
INTERACTION BETWEEN BEN CHIAROT
AND MATTHEW
>> Dave: I DON'T THINK SEAN
MONAHAN SAW HOFFMAN STANDING NE.
JAKE ALLEN DOESN'T THINK HE HAS
E THEY'RE
LOOKING TO SEE WHETHER THIS IST
INDIVIDUAL AND YOU FE HITS IN T
FIRST PERIOD FOR MO JUST A LITT
MORE.
BOARDS WITH CHRIS TANEV
AFTERWARD THE LINE, BRENDAN
GALLAGHER, SUZUKI
>> Dave: ALL CALGARY PENALTIES?.
>> Bryan: CHIAROT BRING A GOOD
STOP, CHIAROT. IT DOWN,
ROMANOV GETS PINNED AND SAVARD
>> Dave: NICIC REWARDED WITH THK
AND TOOK IT T PAD OF
BELL 5G VIEW. HANIFINS IN
FRONT, GALLAGH JAKE
EVANS AND THERE V V